hello everyone
i am priya natarajan i am the current
director of the frankie program
in science in the humanities at yale and
i'm an astrophysicist
i am absolutely delighted that you are
all here for the first convening
of the year so here's wishing everyone a
very happy and healthy 2021.
i want to mention that it is hard not to
celebrate
the recent shattering of a glass ceiling
that we all witnessed yesterday
the swelling in of the first female vice
president
who is black and south asian so i just
wanted to start off by saying that
despite the pandemic and everything
don't know why this took so long
but we are so delighted and proud
to have this happen first i would like
to
recognize and thank um richard and
barbara frankie who are here
with us today for their generous support
of the frankie program and many other
events and
programs at yale and we are
really happy to have you participate so
actively in
our programming as well so i
before i tell you about the exciting
talk we have in store today i wanted to
remind you that uh
we are recording this event and
therefore all participants must
mute their videos and uh as for
submitting questions uh please start uh
sending them as per usual
to the chat and we have a slightly um
altered format today and i will mention
that briefly so we'll start off with the
talk
followed by sort of a brief discussion
um and then the q a so today's talk
as you all know is part of the ongoing
mapping as knowing series
that we commenced a couple of years ago
it was of course partly driven by my own
personal obsession with mapping and
cartography
but it turns out it's a very very rich
intellectual tool
mapping has been a very intellectual uh
important intellectual tool
to study more than just mapping physical
terrain
the history of cartography is of course
as we all know very deeply tied to the
voyages of exploration
and colonial conquest however these very
tools that created those maps of
domination
can be used today to understand better
the legacy of segregation and inequality
that they have left behind
our speaker today is an exemplary artist
who has managed just that use maps to
illuminate geographies of segregation
to raise awareness of how these
divisions
are deeply rooted in our society culture
and our daily lives of where and they
inform
where we live tanika johnson
our speaker today is a photographer
social justice artist and lifelong
resident of chicago's south side
neighborhood of englewood
she's also co-founder of two
community-based organizations englewood
arts collective
and residents association of greater
englewood which seek to reframe the
narrative of south side communities and
mobilize people and resources for
positive change
within her artistic practice tanika
often explores urban segregation and
documents the nuance and richness of the
black community
countering pervasive media depictions of
chicago's violence and crime
as a trained photojournalist and a
former teaching artist she's been
engaged in building an artistic legacy
that has
gained enormous recognition in the last
four years in 2017 she was recognized by
chicago magazine
as a chicagoan of the year for her
photography of inglewood's everyday
beauty
her englewood based photography projects
from the inside
and everyday rituals were exhibited at
root work
gallery in pilsen the chicago cultural
center the harold washington library
center
and at loyola university's museum of art
tonica is going to be talking to us
today about her folded map
project which visually investigates the
disparities among chicago residents who
are map twins
living on opposite ends of streets that
span the city's racial and economic
divides
and brings them together to have a
conversation with this
this project was also exhibited at luma
in 2018 luma is the loyola museum
university's museum of art now an
excerpt of this project is currently on
display at the museum of contemporary
art
as part of the long dream exhibition
since 2018
uh tanika has transformed folded map
into an advocacy and policy influencing
tool
that invites audiences to open a
dialogue and question
how we are all socially impacted by
racial and institutional conditions
that segregate the city in 2020 she
formalized the folded map
project into a non-profit organization
where she serves as the executive
director
she has won many many awards and
accolades i'll just name a few she was
named one of field foundation's leaders
for a new chicago
and was appointed as a member of the
cultural advisory council for the
department of cultural
affairs and special events by the
chicago city council
i'm delighted that after our talk we
will have
we will follow it up with a brief
conversation with our own resident
cartographer
bill rankin who is a faculty in
in the departments of the history of
science and medicine who has worked
extensively
on various uses of cartography and whose
most exciting
recent article was titled and it's very
relevant to what
uh what tanika will be telling us today
it's titled race and the territorial
imaginary reckoning with the demographic
cartography of the united states
following this
uh we will open up for a q a and
um i just wanted to mention uh and thank
um
tai for bringing tariqa and the folded
map project to my attention
and to tanika for so graciously agreeing
to talk
so promptly and we wanted to open the
series this year with her so thank you
so much tanika for
um uh being here and talking today
her work really exemplifies this
cross-section
of what the between the sciences and the
humanities can do
how the tools from science and
technology can be used to understand and
produce
deeper cultural meaning and interrogate
our society and its values
so tanika without much further ado
here's on to you
hi thank you so much for that amazing
introduction
and welcome i'm so delighted to be here
with you all
and excited for you all to view the
folded map film that i did create during
the pandemic
so that i would be able to have an
opportunity to engage with
others despite not being able to do
in-person presentation so i'm
really glad to be here with you all
and excited to have the conversation
with you
after you view the folded map film
great thanks very much so i will go
ahead and talika may i start
yes
i'm from south side chicago inglewood
neighborhood
i'm sure the words you've heard to
describe ingerwood include
black dangerous poor
gun violence however englewood
is where i grew up and still live
before i tell you about folded map i'd
like you to think about
how you came to live in the neighborhood
that you grew up in
or where you live now what influenced
your decision
who did you talk to and while you're
thinking about that
i'm gonna tell you how i came to live in
inglewood
and how i created the folded map project
it all started with my grandmother
marilyn g
tinney she came to chicago from down
south
in 1962 on the tail
end of the great migration she wanted a
better life
to have a professional career
and she achieved it when she came to
chicago
and got a job as an administrative
assistant
at the local social security office
what black folks would call a good
government job
for seven years she saved her money
while working at
the social security office to purchase a
beautiful
two flat brick building on 62nd and
loomis and englewood
the building that i would grow up in
with my mom
my two uncles my childhood was
beautiful unlike anything people would
imagine
in inglewood i played outside every day
i rode my bike with my friends i met my
first friends in life
one of them named raymond him and i
would go to the corner store
every day for cookies pickles and chips
even my grandmother's best friend miss
patterson
lived right next door she had the same
migration story
every summer miss patterson would make
homemade ice cream
and sell it to the kids for 25 cents
it was also on this block that i started
high school
[Music]
i started going to lane tech high school
and for those that don't know it's a
selective enrollment high school
15 miles north of englewood
and it's very diverse with a student
body
of 4 000 students
but every day i would have to be at the
bus stop
by 5 45 a.m just to make it to school
by eight o'clock
and on that every day commute
i would look out the window listen to my
walkman
and notice how my neighborhood
was very different from the neighborhood
that my high school was in
and this was in 1993 so there was no gps
no cell phone if you wanted to go
anywhere you had to know the address
you had to know the streets and so as i
was on the train going to school
i would notice that my neighborhood had
vacant lots and the neighborhood that
lane tech was in
[Music]
didn't have any my neighborhood had
hundreds of storefront churches
and there was none in the neighborhood
my high school was in
[Music]
my neighborhood had so many beauty
supply stores
and i didn't see any up north
and i would always wonder why is that
and there's also one detail
that i paid extra attention to
[Music]
the street i noticed that the streets
were
named the same in inglewood and also 15
miles north
in the neighborhood that my high school
is in streets like
ashland palina walcott
and western and even though those
streets
were named the same they looked
completely different
ultimately i want folded map
to help us heal and get to know each
other
so that we can tear down the racist
walls
that divide us for more information
go to folditmapproject.com
this is tonica johnson for the folded
map project
[Music]
okay senika that was brilliant
and i think we can see that the
point that you are trying to make is
extremely powerful about
how we deal with systemic racism is not
by theorizing about it
but really uh look deeper into our own
personal lives and lived experience
and with something as simple as
ostensibly simple as what you've shown
us just addresses
that are twinned um see how different
life experiences are and the history of
how that came to be
i'm sure the city of new haven would be
a place
that you know it would be fabulous to
have your project come to so i wanted to
share
um the um
the link that um you can all um
tanika do you want to tell us what
people can download from
the website yes um
so in priya you'll share the link
yeah okay perfect so the link that priya
is sharing with you
is a link to um the latest
expansion of folded map which is the
folded map
action kit the contact list
for folded map over the past three years
has
grown to include 800 people who all
wanted to
meet their map twins and since i knew i
wasn't going to be able to actually
facilitate
all of those meetings it it allowed me
to create
a way for people to have their own
self-guided experience
as close as possible to kind of walking
through the shoes of a resident
in their map twin neighborhood and so
the action kit
includes information about the project
as well as the participants neighborhood
so you can see the statistical
difference
from economics education business
corridor
housing and then it also invites you to
describe your own neighborhood to answer
the questions of folded map
and then to actually go run errands in
your map twin neighborhoods
so the the errands um is an invitation
one to go
visit another neighborhood but also an
opportunity to
kind of disrupt the stereotypes that
have been
you know embedded in in chicago and
heads of other neighborhoods
so in order to do that i figured that
just go run errands in another
neighborhood you'll really be able to
not only meet people in that
neighborhood or who are doing the exact
same thing
basic things that we all do but you'll
also be able to understand how different
it is and what disparity looks like how
convenient it is
or how inconvenient that it is so in
addition to
instructing people to do these errands
i'm also inviting them to
share back their experience in the
folded map action kick
workbook which is a very simple workbook
we just
want you to share what you thought how
was the experience
and you can upload that on to folded
maps website
so we have the link that priya sent
where you can fill out
and get a beautiful hard copy that was
designed by my
fellow artists graphic designer friend
from inglewood
um and you can receive it in the mail or
you know if you have enough
ink in your printer you can go to the
website and print it out yourself
so it's it's up to you but that that is
the
uh one of the latest expansions of
foldit map
thank you so much tinika that sounds
really really exciting
and uh wouldn't it be wonderful if every
city and every town in the country did
this
yes so you know after creating the
folded map action kit
um you know a few people who i know from
other states other cities you know of
course mostly midwestern cities since we
are
like the legacy segregation cities they
wanted to adapt it to
their city and so right now i'm working
with my folded map partner dr maria
creason
to create find your fold um we're just
trying to raise money to actually
create this other uh action kit that
will
be hopefully available for free for
other people who want to do folded map
in their
own city we want people to understand
that you know
chicago has a unique grid map that
affords us the opportunity to compare in
a very unique way
but every place that has segregation has
a divide
and that divide is your fold and so
if you can just get people from those
different sides
to have a conversation um then you can
do fold
folded map in your own city so i'm
currently working on that right now
great that sounds five so uh i'm
delighted
um to have uh bill on now
uh bill are you on is your could you
turn your video on please
okay hello everyone thank you so tanika
this is fantastic
uh so great to see this um so i'm gonna
i'm gonna share
um this here um so this is the map that
i made about 10 years ago
um that obviously um you've uh you've
seen
um and i i i want to start just by uh
answering
the questions that you posed to all of
us how did i come to live in the place
that i live
so in the late 1960s my dad
lived at 7 800 south saginaw
which is uh down here on the map and
then in 1970
he he had he was his own folded map twin
and moved up to the northern suburbs
which is where i was born
um and the stories that i hear from him
about when that why that happened was
you know he the neighborhood was
changing um the south side was
was uh was was mixed when he was moved
there in the 60s and was becoming much
less mixed obviously it's now
not mixed at all um and he wanted to
have a
you know he wanted to have a home that
would um he could grow you know could
stay in forever have kids etc
um and that was sort of that's my story
of chicago
um and then the where this map came from
i thought also was kind of speaking to
some of what you're
you're talking about um i actually i
heard from a school teacher
in the suburbs of chicago he had done a
project with some of his
um i think seventh graders trying to
understand chicago
and the way he had done that is to try
to make some maps trying to understand
exactly the things you were talking
about where are their stores
where are their jobs how long does it
take people to get to work
um so they had found all these
statistics uh some from the census some
from the city
about the kinds of things you're talking
about and they've made a bunch of maps
of them
and the one map that just wasn't working
uh was the map of race they just
couldn't make a map that they could
really make much sense of
um and all the maps that they um had
been making all the maps that i had seen
myself
looked like this one in the the bottom
left where you shaded every
every neighborhood a solid color um and
it certainly showed you
uh places like the south side and the
west side but it didn't really give you
a sense of how stark the segregation
really was um and so the map that you
see here the with all the little dots
um is what uh what i came up with um in
my conversations with this
uh middle school teacher as a way to
getting getting kids in the suburbs to
understand
just how stark the divisions were uh and
just
how um yeah just how removed their own
lives were
from the vast majority of people who
live in the city
and it's just it's really great for me
to see you making use of this same map
in your project i'm so happy you made
the map cause i was
searching for i was like oh my gosh does
this exist
and lo and behold i found your map
it's great right actually i've been it's
been uh
i what i love about the map actually is
how many people i hear from
from chicago um so it's not just people
who are interested in you know
mapping uh in general but people in
chicago in particular
and people want me to talk to people in
schools they want you know they want to
put this
in some exhibition somewhere um and it's
about doing work on the city of chicago
exactly
um and the other thing that you and i
definitely have to uh
link up and partner yeah it'd be great
um
and then there's this map that i
actually made when i moved to new haven
um and it was a way of just trying to
understand what was going on in the
place that i was
going to be living in um and how did i
come to live in the way place i live
i live you know in this mostly but not
all pink
area right around here in east rock um
and a lot of it was um it was actually
not so much
talking to people and getting nudged by
realtors and that kind of stuff it was
you know looking up where the
restaurants were where the cafes were
um where was uh where where could i live
close to work and walk in
those kinds of things yeah i think and
for me um i live in the same
neighborhood and for me the main
criterion was
can i walk to work yeah yeah and
uh can i walk to a cafe and i um can i
and i used uh like thai food can i find
thai food i really like thai food
um and so is those those questions that
led me to
uh to really confront the segregation uh
in new haven
because the kinds of things that i
thought were important in my life were
the things that existed
in the predominantly white neighborhoods
um instead of the other neighborhoods
wow mostly you know saying thank you
tanika for that project really great
um and uh and yeah i i'm i'm i'm really
glad to be able to to share that far and
wide now
yeah no this is amazing and i definitely
uh
would love to partner with you on on
find your fold because i definitely
would need some maps for other cities
that i've gotten requests from
so i'll be emailing you that's great
that's great
um and bill we would love to have a high
resolution
copy of your new haven map we would like
to frame it
and make it available to everyone i'm
getting requests on the chat right now
yeah yeah i'm going to send a link in
the chat actually i saw that too
it's on my website it's already up um in
i think full resolution
um quality fantastic yeah yeah so let me
just i'll send
the link real quick oh i think uh cara
already shared it
okay great good great great
so um yeah sorry um tanika thanks to the
pandemic we couldn't uh
actually host you in person but now
there are plenty of reasons for you
you've already seen the map so i hope
you're going to be enticed to come
when you're able yes i would love to and
especially since
my work with folded map has informed my
current project that i'm working on
that'll probably be
within the still working on within the
next year but of course you know when
you talk about segregation
and people and migration you eventually
landed real estate
and you eventually landed all of the
issues that we
talk about with home ownership and so
my current project is focusing on
making more public in an interactive way
the history of land sale contracts
and how they played a significant role
in the
current economic state of greater
inglewood
and it kind of all started with with the
question
of when was greater inglewood's home
ownership rate
ever higher because it's currently like
23 percent
and trying to find the answer
to that question um as well as
meeting amazing people doing a wonderful
research
led me to the information about land
sale contracts
specifically in greater inglewood so
that is what
my next project will be focusing on my
goal is to make landmarkers
for the homes that are still existing
in greater inglewood that was sold on
land sale contracts and
of course most of them are vacant
or demolished so it's a direct
connection
to that kind of discriminatory uh
uh practice
and sharing another map here um this is
i did this for local
newspaper new haven independent number
of years ago
um and there was a local non-profit here
who had a bunch of really good data
about foreclosures in new haven
um and we were we did this this map to
to kind of push back against some of the
narratives um happening with the
foreclosure crisis that we're
highlighting and centering the stories
of of white middle-class families
um and of course their stories were were
serious and
and uh for sure but the vast majority of
actual foreclosures were happening in
in um in communities of color um and so
it's i i completely agree that the
the maps of segregation and um racial
segregation the maps of
housing inequality are the same map
yeah and you know it it really became
clear to me
how maps are such a powerful tool
um in demonstrating so many layers of
disparity which is why
um i partnered with uic's
gis department to create
um an interactive mapping tool
on folded maps website where you can
layer the school clo the schools that
are quality the businesses that
are different on the north and south
side
um because it it becomes even more
clear when you start to add those
specific
layers so i really appreciate the map
you made about the foreclosures because
they
a lot of people don't know how they
disproportionately affect
black neighborhoods
okay great um i think uh there are lots
of questions that are coming in on the
chat so ty
did you wanna sure thank you so much so
compliment first superb project and the
question
uh deepti's curious what sort of divides
you might find in the suburbs
oh wow yeah i actually
want to expand the project to include
map twins from the suburbs because
there's so many ways to
kind of do that kind of map twinning
because streets that are
in chicago do exist in the
northern suburbs that are predominantly
white but even if i was just to compare
the northern suburbs to the southern
suburbs you would see the same kind of
disparities um the southern suburbs
they are now turning more predominantly
black they
used to be white and so you're seeing
the same
kinds of disparities specifically
uh with the quality of the education
um and the values of the homes
so those are the most noticeable ones um
but of course there are many
others of course taxes
that's that's you know once you peel
back all of the other layers you
you'll see that difference as well could
you talk a bit more about the taxes and
what you found there
well i'm still in the process of
learning and researching but there's
definitely
um you know a significant difference
um what is most interesting is that
within the city you know they're
actually
you know black neighborhoods the taxes
are lower
but compared to you know their homes
it's it's actually
higher given everything that costs more
in the neighborhood so just the cost of
living
is surprisingly more expensive in the
poor neighborhoods
um and everything that affects the the
increase of taxes
um you know puts people in a position to
to be displaced and so that's
that's a whole nother project in itself
and and i'm still
reading and learning a lot about what
influences
and what impacts all of that
so feel free to share with me anything
you all find email me because
i'm definitely diving into that
especially with my land sale contract
project
great yes i know i know that in new
haven there is a history of
over assessment in particular latino
areas over assessment of homes
perhaps you know it's disturbing to
think but on the premise that
the residents there would not have the
money to
hire uh real estate experts and
attorneys
to to go and challenge um yes
it's it's so many ways in which it's you
know kind of discriminatory
what's happening now specifically in
chicago is that a lot of
um you know homeowners of color
you know people are buying you know are
paying their taxes ultimately buying
their taxes and they have to
not only fight to you know recover that
but you know they have to stay on top of
paying their taxes because
people you know just predatory they
wait for people to just be late and so
you know black and brown neighborhoods
are subject to that yep there was a
question from one of the participants uh
perhaps bill could you show the chicago
map again
there might be a question forthcoming
and then in the meantime well he's
pulling that up
uh what artists activists do you admire
oh my gosh so many
um i have like their names escaped me
um right now i wanna um
i can't remember her name but the artist
who did the
edits of the new york times articles
alexandria i think it's belle
and she we pasted them across the city
showing the difference between how um
stories that have black subjects uh
are covered and worded very differently
than stories that have white subjects
specifically
um crime related stories and
she did the edits and the rewrites and
showed how and blocked out certain words
so that people could see very
very much like folding map the actual
difference
in how um these subjects were described
and so she's one that i have been
following
and in amazement for a couple of years
um there is an artist in new orleans her
name is
shauna i can't shona griffin she has a
project called
displaced and it focuses
on utilizing maps but showing the
economic centers of new orleans and how
they are connected to
where slaves were sold and so that was
fascinating to me to see the direct
correlation between the financial
centers
in new orleans and how it connects to um
the the history of slavery
and selling slaves and how those exact
locations became the
financial uh districts of new orleans so
that's an amazing project that i have
been you know
nerding out about for a long time now
and using as
inspiration um but i have to think about
the other ones because so many names
come to mind
thank you for the question though
there was a request to see the map again
here i'm just going to share it um
briefly
um but i'll stop sharing so you can see
tanika again
amazing
so um bill i had a question about that
map was all that data publicly available
to you or
was it a bit of uh oh yeah it's all
public um
so the census data uh you can get from
the web
um at the time i got it from the the
census bureau website which is pretty
clunky
now it's much easier the national
historical gis um
nhgis i'll put this in the the chat as
well nhgis.org
um now so it's really easy to get census
data
um and then i got a bunch of data um
from the
city of chicago as well um about parks
and cemeteries and those kinds of things
and then the real work of the map was
was just really figuring out where
people didn't live
um because if you just plot all the data
in kind of big buckets the dots spread
out everywhere
but once you start figuring out where
people are don't live where the
industrial districts are and the
shipping and the cemeteries and those
kinds of things then you really start to
see
the the real separations between the
neighborhood really pop pop into place
um but yeah it's all the data's uh free
and uh on the web
um and i think it really underscored for
me how um
you know getting a totally different
sense of the city isn't necessarily
always about better data it's about
taking the data you have and doing
something really different with it
using dots instead of solid colors right
and uh when i'm um
reading off the chat somebody had a
question that inspired me to ask this
question
wouldn't wouldn't it be really revealing
to overlay on top of this
coveted cases with fatalities like to
layer on so tanika is this something
that you're thinking about
right now actually um very early in the
pandemic i
anticipated that that disparity and i
transformed my instagram page into you
know from being my personal
account to my platform to share all of
this information in the pandemic and so
i did have instagram posts um you know
i'm not
a cartographer in the sense that i make
the maps but that was a dream of mine
uh to overlay because i did have a set
of three posts that showed
chicago segregation in the 50s
60s and then the chicago school closures
that were also different and then
ultimately the chicago
map of the covet cases and
um it it's it's very clear it's very
clear and evident
the disparity um but i did that probably
in may i showed all three of those maps
together so people could see
consistently where
the disinvestment and disparity was
really showing or having a negative
impact
i'm going to share again this is uh from
a page from a pdf
made by the one of the local unions here
in new haven
um so you'll see my map of foreclosures
in the upper left
and then the map of covet in the lower
right um
it's the same pattern yeah it's really
really amazing
um and uh and just putting those side by
side with the same kinds of graphics
i think that makes that point really
really powerfully
yeah the map the color wrap's not mine
um
um and you know what what i have also
been to i was just sharing the link to
the two artists that i mentioned in the
chat um
you know what i've been thinking about
lately especially with
the you know i if you will the reckoning
of
2020 the the fact that uh people are
using
are saying uh systemic racism
um are talking about segregation and
redlining
in more public mainstream media and that
has like never
happened before um you know
i have been encouraging people to
understand that
you know listening and really
recognizing the impact of of
all of these issues on black lives
will afford our country the opportunity
to
understand how all
of these sectors all of the sectors
in our country are impacted by
racism and ultimately capitalism but
those
go hand in hand and it's
the lives and experiences of black
people
that can really show that connectivity
how it is in each of those industries
and sectors
and so there's there's value beyond you
know just having a conscience
in you know valuing black lives but
if we are interested in working towards
i'm a more fair country more equitable
country
you can do that through the recognition
and understanding of how all of those
things
impact black lives and i think the
visual argument is so much more powerful
than even the verbal yeah it is just so
stark
and so visible and compelling right
there's a way in which it is bill
wouldn't you say that is one of the
powers
power of maps
oh he has to get unmuted i know will you
you have to wait for god that's right
that's right
you know i think yeah well for me
thinking back to when i made that
map for the first time i think a lot of
the
um especially growing up the south side
was an idea
it was it was a nebulous place
that i didn't even know quite where it
was or how big it was
um and what i found making the map was
that it really became
much more of a real place and i started
to see lots of other places too that i'd
never heard about
um so uh like you tanika i didn't know
much about the west side the south side
was the
the sort of the thing that everybody
talked about um
and then there's also uh black
neighborhoods outside the um in cicero
i never even knew that there was a black
neighborhood in cicero um and so maps
kind of
they make they have a strong visual
argument that show the segregation but
they also make it really
specific and they make it real they kind
of
anchor it in actual places um in a way
that i think is is
does much more did much more powerful
work for me
um than talking say encoded language
about the inner city or even the south
side which is its own kind of coded
language
in chicago yes when you talk about
geography in chicago you're talking
about people
that's stupid that's what it means in
chicago
further questions uh the first new haven
was split up by
the highways is this true in chicago
yes yes you know just to answer directly
without
you know tracing back to history yes
indeed yes indeed
so it's very deliberate is the point
because highways were planned
very planned i mean i think that's worth
noting
the intentionality behind
thank you uh second question uh from
professor wexler i think it's really
important too she says that there is a
generational aspect to this film
how are you thinking of showing the
history on the map
oh interesting um well i'm first and
foremost starting
with the personal um because
in order for the history to even become
valuable people have to understand the
present day
impact and that you can do
intergenerationally you know and
starting with that
then the connection to the history
can be made so i am actually in the
process
of creating curricular resources or
using folded map as a curricular
resources for teachers
um in social science in
in art where people where the students
can
examine their own environment first
and then use that as an entree into
being connected to the historical
forces decisions that have influenced
their present day life
so so that is the the route i'm taking
in developing the folded map curriculum
and those are the ways in which teachers
and educators have been using it
to help their students understand
understand the history of segregation
i hope that's it for the questions in
the chat priya did you have anything
else
um no i was just um uh going to um to
ask
um um tanika what
um what really as a was it
photography that first got you as you
talked about in the film
that you wanted to sort of you
understood what your trip to your school
was
about in terms of the change in the
landscape
but i was curious about how you got to
photography as a medium as an artist
oh yes and i'll answer that i just saw
uh
laura's clarification to her question
pop-up she was
she was talking about inter-family like
inter-uh
personal within the family um so
in regards to folded map and connecting
it to family history that's also a part
of
using it as a curricular resource having
students
ask their parents ask their their
grandparents the very same question that
i posed to everyone
how did you come to live either in the
neighborhood or in the city
so teachers have definitely made that an
assignment
for students to ask their parents how
and how how did they come to live in
this neighborhood and then to also
ask their grandparents so um
interviewing techniques have definitely
been applied
but priya to go to your question how i
got introduced to photography
um you know really
my family specifically my maternal side
um and my grandmother as well she's an
artist
and my mom is a writer
a poet my uncles that i grew up with
there
also visual artists so art was just
valued so much in my home i often joke
with people that it was valued so much
that
when i decided that i was interested in
music my grandmother and my mom
like bought me a piano so
and i didn't even stick with piano for
for that long maybe like five
six years but i had a piano um so they
really valued
um art and so when my mom and my dad
were married and we were living together
my father had a fascination for cameras
he never evolved into being a
professional photographer but
i grew up around a camera in my face so
much that it
you know sparked a curiosity in me very
early on to
to use it so by the time i was in eighth
grade i was already kind of fascinated
with with cameras
and then taking pictures so that's how
it evolved
anyway um that sounds fabulous so before
i say thank you i just wanted to check
in
that uh richard and barbara frankie old
residents of chicago
so barbara do you have um
any particular question and guy could
you unmute barbara please
yeah i'm trying to mute her now there we
go
yes uh i'm very curious is fascinating
to me
um but i'm also very curious
there is an exodus from
the black community to return to the
south do you think some of the
questions that you have used to nica
um for your project
would also relate to those who are
leaving
yes definitely um you know it's
interesting that you bring that up
because you know
as a you know 41 year old black
lifetime resident of chicago i
definitely
uh can refer to the
exoduses of you know um
black chicago uh 15 20 years ago i
definitely remember
my age group talking about moving to
atlanta
it was a huge exodus of uh
black chicagoans my age at that time
moving to atlanta
um then texas um austin
now you know north carolina and it
mostly dealt with you know not only just
home ownership or the lack of housing
stock in black neighborhoods
and how overpriced um houses were
in other neighborhoods that ended that
you know ultimately are predominantly
white in chicago
but the lack of amenities and resources
and how difficult
it is to live close to where you
probably will be working
and all of those decisions to all of
those elements as well as
the continuation of schools and black
neighborhoods being closed
and going down in quality as a result
of you know the population loss
all of that together made it
bleak for you know young black families
in chicago
which added up to them seeking
opportunity
you know in that reverse migration down
south you know they can take their
chicago salaries their education
and just have a better quality of life
and get a larger home
in some of those southern cities and
states and it's still
kind of happening now
there um any other questions if not
um let's all give uh tanika a big round
of applause
virtual applause thank you all so much
and thank you so much tanika for a
fantastic talk
and what a brilliant project yeah thanks
for taking the time to share it with us
now
i look forward to seeing you in person
oh yes definitely and until then feel
free if you
all are on instagram i live there so
follow me it's tonica j
um i share a lot of the information that
i come across on social media
um as well as you know emailing me
through folded map the website
if you have questions or or requests and
also to
download the action kit if you'd like or
sign up to receive a hard copy
thank you so much bill as well for uh
being part of this wonderful event today
yes thank you so much bill yeah i'm glad
i could be here this is great
i'm gonna email you so uh
[Laughter]
perfect all right uh so i just want to
close
uh and remind you all of two upcoming
events one is an event that we are
co-sponsoring
and that is with the yale quantum
institute it's a
reading by ben oakley who is a nigerian
british
writer who has written wonderful set of
short stories
that i heard him um read in london a
couple and it seems like many years ago
now
on quantum mechanics so it's i invite
you to that
and then our um next uh talk in the
distinguished speaker series is our very
own mark
uh bracket we'll be speaking on february
18. so we'll send you all information
and the poster still then uh stay well
and bye everyone and thanks once again
tanika
bill and charlie for helping with this